so we don't care what anybody says
we don't care how many people dismiss
out of hand oh you're crazy
we think the fact that there are objects
floating around in our atmosphere and
apparently outside it that are not of
human origin but are that it clearly
intelligently controlled is a huge story
in fact it's hard to think of a bigger
story and i know it's not about january
6th
but it's important and it has
extraordinary implications for all of us
scientists have now detected mysterious
radio signals coming from space what
does that mean exactly we don't know
michio kaku is a theoretical physicist
and one of the people who's been paying
closest attention to one of the most
knowledgeable on this he joins us to
explain thanks so much for joining us so
what what do you think this is or what
could it be
well these are called frbs fast radio
bursts they are among the biggest
explosions of radio energy in the entire
universe
they generate more energy than a billion
suns
the energy and radio frequencies is so
great that eventually the entire
universe will be aware of this one
explosion and then the question is what
drives these things colliding black
holes neutron stars being gobbled up
well your guess is as good as mine but
some people
some people believe in renegade theories
that perhaps there's a design to some of
these things
do they seem to be behaving in a way
that suggests a design an intelligent
design
well first of all we've detected 500 of
these
bursts of radio radiation most of them
are irregular they burst once in a
millisecond then they're gone forever
but recently in the chinese radio
telescope
they were able to sew that very their
bursts
are periodic
and some people are saying maybe just
maybe there's a reason for that you see
if you were an alien civilization and
you want to have a coming out party so
to speak wouldn't you want to advertise
to the entire universe that you have
come of age and that's what these bursts
of radiation can do they will eventually
permeate the entire universe now if that
sounds crazy to you just realize that
even on the earth astronomers about two
years from now will celebrate the fact
that 50 years ago we sent a message
saying that we have come of age carl
sagan was the one who famously got this
information together about who we are
and they broadcasted it to the heavens
so that some alien civilization will
pick it up and perhaps encounter us and
say hi we picked up your invitation for
your going coming out party
interesting
well they you know haven't shown any
malicious intent so far uh whatever this
is professor kaku i appreciate you
coming on tonight it's great to see you
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight